hey guys it is the toss of October my
name is Jess and you're watching
gamespot news at now with added couch
the sub respawn has released a new
trailer for titanfall 2 which shows off
the single-player campaign game director
Steve okuda explained that one of the
strengths of the single player is its
variety designer Marc emic Landis added
you can get different Titan load outs
and experience the different flavors of
titans in the multiplayer in the
single-player respawn have also said
that the campaign will give players a
different pace of gameplay explaining we
also have low key moments we are just
progressing through the environment and
exploring you're using your pilot
mobility trailer also shows off some
light puzzle-solving and environment
traversal time 42 is due out on October
28 Rainbow six siege got a new patch
today which stops players from quitting
while they're being interrogated one of
the most recent operator additions to
siege is kuvira who has the ability to
interrogate down to enemy players to
reveal the remaining enemy operators on
the map as you'd imagine an
interrogation exploit emerged where one
we've quit out before being forced to
reveal the positions of their teammates
the 4.3 update which arrives today on PC
and on October 18 for consoles includes
a number of bug fixes server
improvements and new matchmaking bands
for players who kill the same teammate
more than once the exploit has also been
removed too so plays under interrogation
will still a cough up team location info
even if they quit mid interrogation you
can check out the full patch notes in
our story on site finally battlefield
one has arrived today early for those of
you with EA or origin access if that's
you then I don't know what you're still
doing watching this episode because you
could be playing battlefield on either
pc or xbox one right now early access
was scheduled to begin tomorrow button
verified reports have confirmed that the
game is actually playable now even
though EA is not officially announced
any plans to offer up the trial earlier
the play first trial for battlefield one
is both time and content restricted
you'll get ten hours with the version of
the game which includes two missions
from the single-player and four modes
and five maps
for the multiplayer but old progress
made from the trial will carry over to
the full game our field one is due out
on october twenty one head two games but
for our battlefield one early access
live stream and our res infinite review
and i'll see you again tomorrow